we just received some unfortunate news
about the upcoming M3 chip that we've
all been waiting for for the new
MacBooks along with the a17 that's going
to be going into the iPhone 15 Pro and
in this video I'm gonna let you know
what that is and why everything is
starting to align based on Apple's
decisions with for example the 15-inch
MacBook Pro and how that is going to
affect you now everybody's been waiting
for Apple's three nanometer chips not
only because of a huge increase in
performance which should beat out
Intel's best chips in terms of single
core and actually beat the 2 000 14 inch
M2 Pro MacBook in multi-core which is
absolutely crazy in and of itself but
with that it would drastically reduce
heat as we saw with the M2 MacBook Air
that hits 108 degrees Celsius that is
crazy so this ship will be perfect for
thin and light machines especially ones
that are fanless but on top of that also
have a great increase in terms of
battery life because the chip is way
more efficient now talk about the
performance numbers and how we got to
those in just a bit but first we've been
waiting for three nanometer since uh
back in the fall where we had lots of
rumors that the M2 Pro and Max would be
on the three nanometer node as we know
that didn't happen in the M2 Pro and Max
while having some improvements were not
a massive increase because tsmc weren't
able to start producing those chips when
we had that info back in June about
August or so coming out and they only
started to produce them at the very end
of
2022 so everybody was thinking that the
M3 chip would come on the new 15-inch
MacBook Air but tsmc's production began
in late December it's too late for for
that product and now we have some new
news that just came out that they are
having struggles with tooling to create
the three nanometer M3 chip along with
the a17 so because of this they are
straining to produce enough of the
newest three nanometer chips for apple
and they're gonna have a very hard time
meeting demand for these new chimps and
now suddenly everything is starting to
make sense why it is launching later and
why the new 15-inch M2 based MacBook Air
isn't gonna come with this chip and
right now it looks like their yield is
about 55
so that is not that great and they said
that they are looking to boost yields by
around 5 each quarter not each month but
quarter after quarter me eating that for
launching in the fall time it will take
a while for those yields to improve so
why is this bad news for M3 Max and for
the upcoming iPhone 15 Pros well as far
as the iPhones if you remember the
launch of the iPhone 14 pro the Pro
Models which were the only ones that got
the new a16 chip were sold out for over
a month sometimes two months depending
on the configuration and that was with
the a16 which was still based on five
nanometer improved technology so this is
pointing to once again having shortages
of the phones that people want to buy
and with that we've had lots of rumors
of Apple raising the price on their
Flagship devices and I think with these
lower yields that will make that a lot
more likely and finally about to happen
now we know that Apple ordered tsmc
entire supply of three nanometer for
this 2023 year which is crazy so Apple
absolutely wants those chips as many as
they can get but at the same time the
yield is not good and apple folded in
negotiations with tsmc for pricing and
as we saw in tsmc's quarter one earnings
their average sales price for their
Wafers went up by 11.4 percent while
shipments went down by 14 so they are
charging a lot more so what does this
mean for all of you guys waiting for the
M3 chips in the upcoming Max while we
are super excited about these and all
the improvements and performance and
battery life Apple might be less excited
and they might prioritize the iPhone and
for those of you guys that might not
believe me take a look at their earnings
and sales they're during quarter one
which was down iPhones brought in 65
billion dollars compared to just 7.7 for
Max Apple's revenue on Max is lower than
anything else even iPad sell better
Services Macs are the lowest for a few
reasons we saw that Apple's Mac sales
were down 40 percent the steepest ever
forcing Apple to completely shut down M2
Chip production which they've never done
with a new chip now part of it is
because it's not as impressive as the M1
chip for example and because the M1 chip
is still available in the M1 MacBook Air
which we highly recommend in at 800
bucks you can't really beat that machine
people are prioritizing value versus
performance and M1 performance is all
ready good enough for most people which
is why I think the M2 Chip in that 15
inch also makes a ton of sense if
they're not having a lot of yield
meaning they're going to prioritize
iPhone and some machines that have good
profits they need to put these M2 chips
in other machines and the value of the
15 inch is the price tag for the large
screen which we haven't had in many
years Apple's 15 and 16 inch MacBooks
are way more expensive and the
performance is good enough so people
will absolutely buy that machine when it
comes out shortly and when we do get the
M3 chip in the 13-inch MacBook Air that
will have killer performance like even
looking at it compared to the M2 Chip it
is a huge difference and this difference
is backed up by a lot of estimates based
on what we're seeing we first saw leaks
on weiboo for the a17 and then these
numbers were scaled similarly how the
previous scaling has gone with the fa15
series The a16 the A14 so everything
lines up so people that would care about
Optimum performance they will get one of
those machines and the actual volume is
still going to be a lot lower than the
M1 MacBook Air which apple is still
going to be selling along with the 15
inch which is a killer value but will
have lower performance so hardcore
enthusiasts like us will want to buy a
machine like this but for most people
they're gonna just grab an M1 machine or
a 15 inch if they can spend the extra
money to grab one of those now to me
seeing numbers like this with the M3
chip estimates beating out the 10 core
M2 Pro that is amazing especially in
such a thin design that is fanless and
that is something that I would want but
then we once again get to the struggle
of you know getting a larger machine uh
or getting something like this one with
better performance which doesn't make
sense but that will allow as much supply
of those three nanoid chips to be used
for the iPhones which are the ones that
sell like crazy so if you want to get an
M3 chip I would say make sure you're
ready to order right away because the
supply is going to be limited and if
you're on the fence with a 15 inch
coming out consider getting that with
the M2 Chip and enjoying it instead of
trying to wait longer you guys let me
know your thoughts down in the comments
section below click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those videos
about the full performance right over
there this Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
thank you